[Music]
mike tyson raves in full bloom have
captured the art of fighting
the hollywood reporter says it's mallet
meet scorcese
[Applause]
in full bloom available now on amazon
prime video
and now
this is truly the moment we've
all been waiting
[Applause]
it's time
introducing fighting out of brownsville
new york
usa presenting
the heavyweight undisputed
champion of the world
iron mike
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to hot boxing with mike tyson
i'm your boy zab judah and i'm here with
mike tyson and we have a special guest
today i mean a guest that's so special
man bruce buffer we'll talk to the
people
oh mike thank you you know just uh
introduction by you being uh special and
it's really special for me brother
no listen um you have such a um
such an interesting life you know
meeting your brother michael
you guys happen to be doing the same
stuff and your acclaim
too you know you guys are both on top of
your game and
how's that feel you know it's amazing
because um
back in the 80s you know when you were
lighting up the ring and
cover sports illustrated i'm following
you like there's no tomorrow and all the
other great boxers of the era because
that was
the one of the greatest errors in boxing
that was really amazing no no no
they were magical that's the magical
magical every week we saw the best fight
the best right
and i'm a huge boxing fan um my dad was
teaching me boxing as a kid
right out of the womb we're watching
boxing on saturdays you know why world
of sports
and it was boxing every week boxing
boxing boxing out comes this man
very handsome debonair james bond
looking dressed to the nines
brought a whole new flare to the world
of announcing and i became a huge fan
but i had an issue because every time he
came out
and they flashed his name on the screen
it said michael buffer
i used to own telemarketing companies in
my 20s right and this is before the
internet
and like we all did back then when
you're in another town you look in the
phone book you see it there's a tyson
you see if there's a buffer or whatever
i never saw my last name in a phone book
in any city in the united states and
here's this man
you know michael buffer and i'm like wow
what's going on i started getting this
weird feeling in my
stomach so i'm calling don king's
offices bob aaron i'm trying to get a
little more information on the man
and um about six months pass and people
are coming up to me is getting more
popular and say hey is that your brother
michael buffer the guy that goes let's
get ready to rumble and i'm like
no my brother's brian who i grew up with
my whole life
so long story cut short my dad and i are
taking a road trip up to san francisco
one day and i'm like dad
i'm telling the same thing i'm telling
you people are coming up to me it's
almost daily now
because boxing is a water cooler
conversation on a monday after the
weekend fights
and i said dad do you have any idea who
this is and i got this mike
i think that's your brother yeah
what i'm like 29 years old i'm like are
you kidding me
and he said well son i never told you i
and he never told me he was married
briefly um
when he was around 20 it was during
world war ii
uh he was called overseas to do his part
in the war he came back
a child was born a divorce ensued and um
the last time he saw the child i think
was when he was two and a half years old
and you know it's one of those stories
that happens right and so lo and behold
uh michael was raised by foster parents
i know he explained that to you when he
was on his
your podcast before um under the name of
huber
and when he went in the army at around
20 during the vietnam era
uh they said your birth certificate says
you're michael buffer you're not michael
huber
right and he had great great parents
that raised him and he they stabbed him
it's like you're michael buffer
and had that not happened we wouldn't be
sitting here having this conversation
right now wow so that's one of those
forks in the road that happens in life
so he was doing a an event out here at a
small venue
uh that the goosens used to put their
fights on in the valley that's no longer
around
and i my brother brian are watching the
fights with him tonight and we said dad
why don't you
call leave a message see if he'll call
you back so my dad did michael called
back
they got together for lunch turned out
to be his his son
right now i'm like i you know i might
not at this age exactly correct but i'm
like 29 michael's in the area of 43.
you know there's a 13-year difference
and uh with that being said we got
together for dinner as a family after
they had that lunch they got along
very very well and in walks i'll never
forget this night in walks michael
looking as amazing as he always looks
i'm a huge fan
and like okay i'm a fan but now this is
my blood this is my half
brother walking in i can't even begin to
tell you what that felt like
and we got along great we all got along
great and
from then on with the companies i owned
i had two companies
you know successful making the money
beach house living the life the whole
bit
but i was traveling and i would go to
vegas i would go to new york i would i
would stop in to see the fights michael
and i would have dinner we'd go out
together
1992 evander holyfield riddick beau won
at the thomas and max sold out so i'm in
the audience and i'm watching everybody
going crazy when michael's doing let's
get ready to rumble i mean you've got
nicholson jumping up and holding
going nuts and everybody's just going
nuts right and this light bulb went off
in my head because i've been a marketer
and a brand or
you know a businessman before i'm an
announcer my whole life owning a number
of different companies
i went back to my room that night
instead of going out and partying and
playing blackjack and all the stuff we
love to do and we're in vegas
and i sat down and i couldn't stop mike
i just kept writing like three pages of
notes
like trademark this five words properly
you know
protect it uh keep the boxing ring as
his base like the hbo box ring
especially
branch them out put them in every form
of sports and entertainment there is
movies ready to rumble tv shows thinking
video games toys
you know thinking all the stuff that can
be done and i just couldn't stop it's
like i'm just sitting there i'm just
going like this
so i contacted michael again long story
cut short i basically in
so many words said michael i i want to
make you richer and more famous than you
ever dreamed
hopefully myself in the process i'm
willing to sell my two companies i'm
burned out i'm not passionate about what
i do anymore because i live my life on
passion everything i do would do with
passion
right and i had this passionate moment
thinking what i could do with him is his
partner
and i said let's the best thing to do
here is i want to become
your manager right and also want to
become your partner
because not only do i want to help you
get in every form of sports and
entertainment
take these five words put it on the tip
of everybody's tongue make it part of
american culture
i called it the clarion call to the pure
integrity of the competitive spirit that
was my term for let's get ready to
rumble like
you know every time you hear it it's
like we got to go out and do our thing
right
and michael in so many words said well
how are you going to do it and i said
i don't know but if i'm going to give
all this up you better believe i'm going
to make this happen
lo and behold became his manager became
partners
started working it due to his brilliant
ability to perform and do everything he
does so well i mean let's face it he's
legendary the greatest announcer of all
time
that's right there's no question and i
say that with complete respect and love
for my brother
and um it just went on and it caught on
and everything started catching and the
first product i have i would go to trade
shows
you know around the country and i would
make i go to kinkos and make these promo
kits
they cost me 15 a kit back then because
you know everything was different back
then
and i'd stock up on them and i'd walk
the floors and i'd shake hands and take
names and i'd see
products that would be great let's get
ready to rumble on it i'd pitch to
people on it
and i was just an animal i go to the
boxing events and i'm shaking hands and
taking names and
making appearance deals for them any way
i can and things that come across
michael's desk he's handing me to take
care of for him
and it just started building and within
a year our first product was a talking
key chain
right it was a boxing glove when you
press the button of course let's get
ready and rumble came out of it right
and there was also a mug you know that
had like a football on it you know for a
football and you watch football and you
press the button and drink it i said
let's get ready to rumble that was our
first two products
and then it just started taking off and
our big hit was the ready to rumble
boxing video game
if you ever played video games it came
out in the chat yeah yeah
and when we came out with the ready to
rumble boxing video game in the first 24
hours along with nine other games that
were released with the dreamcast
system uh combined it did like 97.1
million dollars in sales
in 24 hours right which has been
surpassed since then by call of duty and
all that
but it was either variety or hollywood
phenomenon
yeah it was phenomenal yeah phenomenal
that's yours
yeah yeah exactly and we're just you
know it's like we're making
entertainment and sports history here
as we go along and it just started
feeding my fire
you know and i just kept going and i
sold the two companies i quit with the
money i had in the bank because
sometimes you just got to go for it
right which you know better than anybody
and you know better than anybody
it's taking what i call the puncher's
chance so we went for it
and it just all worked out beautifully
michael and i we get along great
um it's it's teamwork it's total
teamwork he does what he does
i'm the man behind the man behind the
rumble you know the sheriff of the
rumble the man behind the rumble
but michael's the talent it's michael's
he did it he created it and it's just a
beautiful story
something that we both take away from
the business and the brains
department is it safe to say the
business and the brains take a business
and a brand you know it's just i saw it
i realized where it could go
and i just wanted to put everything i
could into it to do what i told him i
was going to do which make him richer
and more famous than he ever dreamed
and i wanted to announce boxing back
then i said i'd love to be an announcer
and we discussed it it's a confliction
of interest right that that
i did announce some boxing i i announced
under cards with michael jordan
yeah finally you are right now yeah yeah
yeah
yeah well when the ufc came along
mike in 93 i've been a martial arts
since i was 12. right
i've got three black belts in various
styles i've studied different styles i
boxed a lot
which styles are you which styles toxido
i'm a second degree black belt i have a
black belt in another hybrid style
called jiu-jitsu
but i don't pretend to be a black belt
in jiu jitsu is the french sabot
person that created the jiu-jitsu dough
that had it he would bring me in
and i would teach his black belts and
jiu-jitsu i would teach some striking
right because ground fighters don't
always adapt well to striking
where i think strikers can adapt better
to ground fighting when you teach them i
just
something i've observed so i would work
with his black belts
spar with them you know give them
striking techniques and all to back up
their jets
and like eight months into it he
presented me with a black belt
so i got an honorary black belt but i
don't consider myself a black belt in
jiu-jitsu yes
yeah okay okay so i'll go with all these
you know what i like that because
i think i got something similar to that
you know my father's the ninth degree
black villain
yeah listen his father he's just
interesting him and his crew back there
really did this stuff yeah my father how
interesting he is he had to come from
somewhere yeah yeah pop stick it to a
you know a high level i was looking at i
said you know you was in
what is it called thais it's korean it's
actually chuck norris's original korean
art
that he started studying in the air
force and i grew up in philadelphia
and i moved to malibu when i was 15. my
dad ran fortune 500 companies
and we eventually moved out to malibu
and when i went out to malibu
i met chuck norris's fighting partners
bobby burbitch and pat johnson
and a couple of his black belts were my
best friends in high school and all we
did was we surfed we trained and we
fought
you know wow surfed every day trained
who got the best of all
for me who got the best of who we both
had our
favorites right everybody you know what
it's like that yeah
right well people don't know bruce lee
introduced um
martial arts to the hood when he like in
the 60s he was in the hood cheating
people in the
comfort they didn't want him to they
were teaching everybody
especially the people black people in
the hood yeah bruce lee was out here
teaching a lot of people
and i when i moved to malibu one of my
best friends was steve mcqueen's son
chad mcqueen steve mcqueen trained with
steve mcqueen trained with bruce and
steve mcqueen and i were really good
friends the last six years of his life
and bruce would come to his house this
was before i met him and then chuck
would come to his house and they'd train
or he would go to chuck's dojo and
steve would get in there and mix it up
you know he was he was a bit of a badass
himself when he had to be
and i remember there's this plaque on
his wall which his son still has that i
would just love to have because i'm a
big collector of sports and
movie memorabilia and it's the science
certificate
that bruce lee gave steve mcqueen of his
graduation from jeet kune do
and it's a beautiful certificate signed
by bruce signed by steve can imagine
what that's worth
right big love to have that piece yeah
yeah because you know when i was a kid
if it wasn't for bruce lee and chuck
norris maybe i wouldn't got as deep into
martial arts as i did back then me
though yeah
same thing that's what my dad said my
dad was a bruce lee fanatic
total yeah i think everybody was just
walking around tossing around your head
just walking around yeah listen i
remember we were little who was the kids
we would be in the movie theater right
and next time we see guy in the front
scene he has some
nice jury on the thing that goes
by wow i kicked him right in the head
and snatching and watching jerry ripped
his pocket
uh many times have you seen
under the dragon yeah oh so many times
chuck norris
yeah i picture bolo he looks great he's
like 80 years old
he looks fantastic does he wow you know
when i watched under the dragon of
course one of the first things i did was
i had to get a pair of noon chucks and i
can't tell you how many bumps on the
head i gave myself
training oh those are myself
exactly i'm trying to be blessed in that
famous scene
you know and then and then you know back
in those days the martial arts movies
that came out
i mean you know what real fighting's
like you know what real fighting's like
and
and it was depicted i think the ufc
really made it clear what real martial
arts street fighting you know can be
like
or is like but you know it was back in
the early days of steven seagal
and jean-claude van damme and you know i
used to love all those movies right
right
yeah you know i'd be first in line to
see those movies totally
see bruce lee was elaborate bruce lee
was a martial artist but bruce lee was
the street fighter
yeah right he likes to fight for real
[Music]
he likes to do it for real gotta respect
that because
you know with all respect to the martial
arts but there's a lot of people walking
around with black belts on but they've
never been face down
never been hit everything yeah somebody
was told even his but not on the street
it was a conversation
i don't know the judo expert and he was
talking to bruce lee
and he was talking to bruce lee
something to the fact
what were you doing grappling and he
said
i equate grappling to being on the floor
and i
expect being on the floor being stomped
and the guy says what do you mean he
said
what do you mean being stomped and they
said well i'm fighting three or four
guys i'm not fighting one guy
and i just blew my mind and he talked
about no i'm on the floor i'm gonna get
started and then every guy said
well i'm grabbing how are you gonna get
stopped well no i'm not gonna let you
grab me because i got i'm fighting three
or four
guys right and it blew that guy's mind
he think it was just
three or four guys right well you know
another like bruce lee is um
let's face he's one of the original
mixed martial artists right which was a
term that wasn't even created until
about six or seven years after the ufc
was actually or five years after the ufc
came on the scene mixed martial arts was
a term that came in later
um but there's also another man which
i'm sure you're aware named jean labelle
who's one of the original mixed martial
artists one of the greatest grapplers
ever has been in a ton of movies
um there's just so much history joe
lewis the guy named joe lewis used to be
here's the kickboxing and then the super
football wireless
badass mm-hmm it's to watch those guys
come in
i used to narrow myself after bill
wallace i mean i just wanted my right
leg to be my right leg was pretty
fast
never forget it one thing that changed
my life is when i figured all the
training that i had and the altercations
i've dealt with in my life as we've all
gone through
in 1991 um a friend of mine who director
john milius
who wrote and directed conan the
barbarian was involved writing
apocalypse now
i directed and was involved in red dawn
you know the original red
dot film he called me one day and he
said you know i know you train a lot
but why don't you come train some jiu
jitsu with me i said i've trained some
jiu jitsu because well you never trained
gracie you're just mm-hmm i mean
so he took me to a place in torrance
which was the original gracie torrance
gym
right dojo and we go in and
out comes this skinny young kid right he
goes hi my name is hoyce
how are you and he goes come with me so
he takes me to one of their rooms
all padded up go in closes the door
and he looks at me says i understand you
do a lot of kickboxing
let's go at it come at me take my head
off right
and i said you want me to put on some
gloves he goes no just come at me
right so we're alone so i go at him you
know i'm game
pop pop gets underneath my punches takes
me down on the ground i know you're
waking up
shaking his head 45 seconds later
he's got me in a side choke and i'm
going out right he's like tap
tap tap so i tap and i never forget this
he gets up in the guard he straightens
out his key and he looks at me says see
isn't it nice not to get hit in the face
right
wow that just changed a lot of theories
but you know i knew every street fight i
was ever in
whether it was on the beach or on the
street it always went to the ground at
some point it always winds up
this is also interesting i know why i
come up street fights don't last long no
no they don't last long
listen a minute for a street fight for
long a minute yeah i think at 20 seconds
it's like
a minute for a street fight just a
minute then two guys with skills
yeah they got something they got some
kind of stuff
yeah yeah they got to be they're facing
off i got 10 12 rounds of the ring
starting to stream they be taking breaks
yeah
jumping grabbing yeah exactly that's a
lot man
we've all had our experiences god knows
you and you have had time so
tell me what what what is uh i mean you
don't watch
tons of usc fighters what is one of some
of your ultimate favorites to watch
you know it's a very hard question for
me to answer
at times because i've announced every
ufc fight basically since uh started in
96
a thousand events and thousands of
fights so i'll give you an example of
something but
george sapierre one of the greatest one
of the one
all-around role models of the sport in
and out of the octagon a gentleman class
and just a supreme athlete and fighter
you'd give george saint pierre a
basketball and he'll be in the nba in 10
months
i know i like people some people say
things and i love
matt hughes matt hughes i mean just a
wrestler personified
[Music]
um
i had a pleasure knowing arturo i mean
god bless arturo yeah
um but you know bj was doing street
fighting
at like 13 and fighting 20 year old men
bigger than him
i mean we're talking not just the sport
we're talking
like kimbo slice you know who was doing
his backyard fights i mean bj was game
to do whatever it took
and he had that reputation yeah you know
he's a god in hawaii
a guy yeah he's my boy man you get back
to like chuck liddell
right randy couture contour hat
that was just really authentic you're
stumping me doing this it's gonna last
yeah yeah the beauty of the ufc is that
when it started in 93 you know
it was just fine
he came on the scene at like 240 pounds
you know what i'm jacked up dead fastest
lightning oh yeah
fastest lightning fascinating his first
fight i guess
i think i did was in brazil in 97 or 98
against vondelay silva oh you won
that yeah he just came at him and just
took him across the octagon and he was
in the mountains
yeah yeah total monster but you go back
to those old days when we had
very little rules you know guys fighting
three times a night yeah
the headbutts all that type stuff it had
to be changed for us to become a
mainstream sport
and family television exactly
but we were taken off tv you know back
it was around
um 98 or 97 we were taking off tv when
when senator mccain again bless senator
mccain i'm
a big fan of his but he came out and
said we were human [ __ ] fighting and all
that and
we were taken off in demand well that's
what it really was
back then that's what they accepted in
the east
well you know in the early days they
used to build like some in so many words
like somebody's gonna die
you know i don't think they really
realize that when they started it when
horian and
and robert meyer was back then i think
they were in it for like you know we're
going to do three four events
maybe they didn't think it was going to
go as far as it went but with the whole
thing changed thanks to people like big
john mccarthy and others that worked on
the rules and started applying the rules
but when we started going under a little
bit where we were the fastest growing
pay-per-view on tv
and then we were taken off in demand
losing a potential like 66 million
potential pay-per-view buyers and we
were only on direct tv and we went down
to 16 million or so potential
pay-per-view buyers we were kept alive
by the internet and by the incredible
fans of the ufc mixed martial arts ufc
fans are the greatest fans
they're so loyal right so we stayed
strong
but the big change was when dana white
and the fertitta brothers bought the ufc
in 1999
that was a big change because we were
down to maybe 1500 people in an arena i
remember doing a show in louisiana
and there was a man who passed away
since then named kevin randall
i'm a great fighter great fighter
wrestler great fighter
physique everything um came out from
ohio
yes exactly so i get in my ifb in my ear
i'm about to announce the main event
they said
buff you got to tell them there's not
going to be a main event i'm like what
he goes kevin slipped on a pole in the
back and knocked himself out
and there's going to be no main event
and i'm thinking here come the cans and
bottles
right so that was like one of the lowest
points and then when dana white and the
fertittas bought it
i went to dinner with them after a
boxing event in vegas where
big john mccarthy and i were kept with
the group and we had dinner and i could
see the passion that dana was talking
with and lorenzo and frank fertitta had
for the sport
that was the turning point that was the
big turning point for the ufc
they had the money they had the business
acumen and they took us to where we are
today
uh obviously we've been bought out by
wme you know the biggest media company
in the world
the ufc sold for 4.2 billion dollars the
highest price ever paid for
sports franchise in the united states
ever dana white goes high man
dana white likes him you go hard the
thing about dana white
you know i mean he's my friend i respect
dan i've known him for many years i love
working for dana he's a maverick
you know there's mavericks in business
he's a maverick he's a beautiful person
i don't know about that magic [ __ ]
it's beautiful yeah he's a great great
guy very high
he's beautiful but look at it mike he
and zab he's gone through
the sale obviously made a tremendous
amount of money for it
most people would kind of like walk away
his passion is still strong
he's banging it out every day he's out
there doing everything and still taking
us on the path that we're on
greatest thing in the world there's no
end to this we've seen the beginning but
we're never going to see the end of it
fighting
you know i mean i'll be going before you
but it's it's you know what it is i've
got a first-class seat
on an amazing rocket ship that just
keeps going uphill
and it's quite a ride mike i've been at
this you know 25 years february 16th was
my 25-year anniversary
congratulations thank you thank you
thank you thank you very much i
appreciate it
silver anniversary but i'm not stopping
that's right i've seen you in the
audience going crazy at ufc fights
i've seen you having a blast and i'll be
back
i can't wait you know we're doing 15 000
people in jacksonville florida in april
oh it'll probably sell out and um we
dated that april what
april uh 27th i think it is if i'm not
mistaken 20 yeah 27th
um so that's going to be great the fans
are going to start coming back to the
show
there are babies she's in the gym
working out
oh look at that that's a good exercise
wow 12 years old throwing muay thai
knees yeah she's
a serious worker yeah you're a proud
father aren't you oh i'm
so proud yeah i just don't want them to
be like me
put their whole life in this i want them
to save a little for themselves
your teacher and uh i'm sure you're
doing a great job mike
jeff you have kids yes yeah i have uh
four girls and four boys and a set of
twins
oh yeah twins i'm serious yeah i never
have your boys
i always kid i've never been married
i've almost been divorced twice i always
say that but
i i've helped raise two boys my partner
kristen
um i'm godfather to one since you know
since they were born it's been one of
the greatest experiences of my life
mm-hmm
children are beautiful yeah they change
you they change you and make you good on
the right foot no matter
no matter what you're doing you're gonna
hop on the right foot dealing with kids
they make you keep your guard up that's
fine
100 yeah tell me about your family life
my family life i was very lucky to have
incredible parents
and to be raised and i was born in
oklahoma
for like nine months we went to dallas
then to philadelphia i spent most of my
life in philadelphia before the age of
15 which i consider my hometown
i learned to fight in philly learn to
fight a little more tough town
tough town valley's a tough town got a
brawl at him
exactly and then i moved out we moved
out to malibu as i mentioned earlier
and um i saw surfing once in france when
i was 11 years old on a trip with my
parents
always wanted to do this what was that
like going from philly
to malibu i had to show you shotgun it's
gotta be
culture shock hey dude yeah hey dude
you know back east i would spend money
i listen i live the point break life
remember the movie point break
yeah i didn't rob banks all right i did
everything else
i knew a lot of those bodhi types the
patrick swayze
tough guys it was a great stuff the
tough guy though
all the time i know you got it what did
you think about service when you got
there from philly you like
surfaced no i i you know i saw how tough
they were
sometimes they die that boy goes down
and come up boy
it comes up so fast they break your neck
what's that what's up like like
sometimes the boy goes in the wood and
comes up so quick
shoots up oh yeah and shoots a boom man
you might break
breaking jewelry there's a famous surfer
so quick
there's a famous surprise named jerry
lopez years and years and years ago
the classic uh king of pipeline the
famous break in hawaii
and he knows that break better than
anybody he was surfing he took a bad
fall the surfer went up his
anus right pierced him had to you know
had to get the bag the whole bit i mean
surfing is
it's a tough sport yeah yeah yeah you
got to be happy dang
knock you out cold let's break your joy
boom not your coat
oh yeah i cracked a rib with my
surfboard a little bit
but getting back to uh malibu is like
you know i get there i'm used to
atlantic city
yeah which you know all right dirty
though you can't it's not it's not
malicious you'll get your disease you'll
get to the sea you
put stuff in a cup yeah purple but as a
15 year old kid i'm at the beach and
there's all these blonde girls running
out of the water i'm like this is not
like atlantic city that's
really great i'm in nirvana right now
and they're friendly and friendly
yeah that blew me away i thought they're
not from the back east let's not say
that
no no not like this way
well i got into the surfing and of
course doing school and um
i had to go to santa monica to go to
school and i was surf
every day and then a steve mcqueen when
he where he lived they had the best
surfing spot
in malibu during three months steve and
queen had some cool cars
oh my gosh the car his garage it would
knock you
out of here still has a bunch of his
cars he's known to have a cool car
total motorhead you know just leveling i
bought one of this cars
um oh the mustang
i believe it was the entertainer and the
elton niles and john
he used to be right he's live right next
door to me oh
wayne newman yeah oh way newton he had
one of his cars yes he had ever had mama
engaged cause he had
tons of cars over there wow people
closely bought facilities
yeah he had an airplane in the crib yeah
the airplane
was probably got an airplane on the
property and now listen yeah he had all
the property
um where did he had all probably like
500 he had so much property
i i um i lived on this property it was
just so much
he was just a maverick of the plane
where the prop
it wasn't like he didn't use it he just
stayed there just stayed there for him
like a statue a real plane
like that well actually that really like
um
steve in the last like five years of his
life he was
had a fear of heights so his way to
overcome it was he started flying planes
but he would fly the double wing open
cockpit planes
right and i remember we were surfing one
day in front of his house and he came
down and did a whole loop to loop
in the air above us but with no tap yeah
no top
you know open cockpit i think one was
called a pit karen which was a nail
salon
man but he had a big hanger up in santa
paula
which was about a half hour north where
we lived in malibu and i would go up to
visit him and he had all his big
collector he had all his toys he had
tons of cars there
and he had his two planes there and he
just loved his
you know the lifestyle of just flying
and being on his ranch with all his
animals and his wife barbara at the time
and
just a really downer have him for the
great plane ride
as well yeah it's crazy i didn't go up
in those planes with them
no i didn't do this though no a little
little little crazy
i get a little fear of heights myself
i'll take it off in a big way but i got
a little fear of heights of myself
yeah i'm i'm scared i don't know malibu
was a great style i got into the whole
uh baywatch routine you know the
lifeguarding and
you know i just i mean frankie avalon
you meet
great people you know you meet great
people as well yeah
great people but it's a tough culture
and surfers fight a lot very territorial
yeah
yeah very terrible but can they fight
there were some tough guys
yeah and there's ones that couldn't
fight but they just wanted to fight and
they got the
snot kicked out of him by the right guy
it's kind of tough to have a fight in
the water with a surfer you get knocked
out you in the water you're going to
drown like that's a double
get exchanged but you know that when you
get out on that beach
things are going to happen yes yeah
getting grounded pounded on the sand is
a little different than the octagon
it's sound over that sound that's saying
don't give and a lot of surfers at the
time were
very much like myself very much in a
martial arts so you know
it's what it is we all have this
oh is that a water bag oh man i love
this bag hey bruce i beat the hell out
of this aqua bag
man it's going right through it and it
doesn't hurt my hand these that's why i
love these bags
i love these bags too because um again
the whole water fill thing i love the
effect i feel like i'm hitting somebody
for real
you have a broken hand that's perfect
and for me with my shoulders is the
perfect bag for me to work i agree 100
yeah i'm gonna keep one in all my gym
and put one in my house
my kids are gonna hit it this is gonna
be my life now the aqua bag
the greatest bag for everybody aqua bag
water is beautiful
it's better than leather that's right
there you go
what is better than leather what did
bruce lee say be like water
he likes water baby so mike
one of the things on my list that i've
wanted to do for a long time
and i finally met the perfect partners
for it and i know you don't drink
right but i came out with my own spirit
and i'm a big bourbon fan but i created
this
with you in mind because of the title
and it's called puncher's chance oh
hunter's chance bourbon and we just came
out with this last year
it's selling faster than we can make it
yes it's a big hit we got a 95
taste rating from the board one of the
highest uh taste rates i have friends
that do drink
you do yeah well then this is for you
mike so
this was made for you in in essence
again the spirit we had is
puncher's chance puncher's chance i've
been an underdog my entire life
and everything i've done even when i
sold the companies and took over michael
and
everybody was telling me like really
you're going to do that i said yeah i'm
going to make this happen
so puncher's chance right one punch can
change the whole life 100
check it out 100
thank you punches thank you champ
everybody
punch his chest that's for you mike i'm
really proud about that
so that's it so there you go
you're nice so this is gonna you know
embar this is going to be cool right
like give me a shout out punches chance
and you're next that's it
wait i don't want to cause any problems
oh that's the good thing that's going to
be this guy coming at the press i got to
punch his chest that's right
shout out to this and i'm good i can't
say enough about it you know working on
different things and
uh like it's fun it's like the video
games i made and the toys i made with
michael and
we have other products coming out i've
got my own cologne and toiletry line
coming out
and an energy product line so you know
how it is mike you know
you got your ip you got your brands app
you understand too you've got a lot of
work
yeah just like how easy people think is
no it's not
you gotta sell the company yeah it's
it's
gotta build it up to sell it you gotta
build it up and you're gonna make it
work
you gotta watch over it these are
problems that i'm i'm looking forward to
right now
yeah there's good problems to have yeah
life is all about challenges yeah hey
listen guys coming from brownsville and
philly
i think that we uh we happen to have
these kind of challenges of course
of course absolutely similarities in
life but all over
all of our milton berle told me that god
bless his soul
in 1990 i guess i lost my fight to bust
and i said
what i said i said something like oh man
i really failed he said no you didn't
fail
you just made 30 million dollars you
fail you got to go back to brownsville
you can't get back
that's right that's when you fail i said
whoa right
one thing i always remember about you
mike is that cover you had on sports
illustrated
you know when that first story i read
about you i'll never forget that
i thought this is the baddest mofo i've
ever seen
you know i just glued to every one of
your fighters and i had the pleasure
watching you fight live too
you know and on more than one occasion
it's just memories that
those days of boxing i don't think could
explain it so were you
were you one of those that mike trained
to get your popcorn and drinks and stuff
and sit down before the bell rings
back in the day if you used to go to
they come in on the main event
coming in the third round second round
that shot me are you oh so you was there
when the battle run
fight that's dope i'm there for them i'm
there to watch a night of fights
okay i mean you're either a boxing fan
or not that's one thing in vegas it's
funny you know when the big fights
happen like you said
mm-hmm and all of a sudden the co-main
or the main comes around it's all full
right it's like wait
yeah it's like in the ufc too you know
dana gives
usually a 50 000 bonus to the fight of
the night or the performance of the
night
i can't tell you how many times it's
been like the very first prelim at four
in the afternoon
right i'm going to go to a night i go to
a night of fights i'm going to a night
of fights
everyone huh fight of the night might go
to somebody that fought
one o'clock in the afternoon exactly
exactly
yeah and they're there to prove
themselves yeah you know i think the
minimum in the ufc more than any other
mma organization is
at a minimum you get 10 000 a show and
10 000 if you win
well if you get a 50 000 bonus on top of
that you guys remember when you were
young fighters fighting for whatever you
thought
listen no no i remember when um
i was fighting for like i think a
hundred it was 100 grand my first fight
and um they were saying that he's too
young to fight a main event
because he's only 18 and he can't find a
main event
and i was i wasn't mad when i was mad at
the president i wasn't going to get the
money
right 20 000. i wanted that money so bad
was it twenty thousand or a hundred
thousand twenty twenty one a hundred
thousand
hundred thousand the hundred thousand i
wanted that so bad never had a hundred
thousand dollars
you know of legitimate money in my hand
so i was like oh my god please
still keep the cash and because of your
age they made it go down to not the main
event for like eight rounds
and then um i still got the hundred
thousand i was just so
paranoid oh please let me get the money
please yeah yeah how'd that feel when
you finally got that
did you hold the cash in your hands or
just put it in an account no i was just
an account buy
some new i could buy some goodies yeah
yeah yeah i buy some goodies
it's amazing cause a hundred thousand
back then so that was like a million
dollars that's
probably why i did
you know that was yeah but you go to the
ufc i see you
yeah oh i love the ufc and you get there
early yeah we didn't watch it on the
fight no but i was saying that because
my tyson trained fighters i mean fans on
how to watch fights
that was that quick knockout quick
knockout yeah you wasn't there early
you missed it you'd be at the popcorn
stand like what is over people walking
out you're like what
i missed it yeah it'd be over so yeah
yeah it's like watching george foreman
you know when he won the heavyweight
championship back and
he was getting straight up the whole
time right yeah michael
michael moore more michael moore yeah my
parents were at that fight
and when they never leave a fight early
and for some reason they had left
and when they got to their coming
outside they're hearing he was like oh
never leave another fight again ever
yeah yeah joey's got a big heart big
heart
i love watching
incredible incredible yeah is there any
uh
ufc fights that you looking looking
forward to or
interested in jon jones john yeah jon
jones coming back as heavyweight oh
you have a good fight with if that guy
beats um the gentleman from ohio he's
tough
guys well you got you got stephen
and francis angano fighting not this
weekend but next weekend on the 24th
he beat francis before
in the octagon as well as the square
squared ring you never know anybody can
win on anything
absolutely absolutely and in
heavyweights as
you know better than anybody mike
that's francis punch but stipe is
proving himself probably to be the
greatest heavyweight ufc fighter ever he
was great
with his record francis is a beast i
can't wait to announce that fight
and then jon jones as i understand it
from dana what i've read in the press um
because i'm as privy to the news as you
are when i read it
uh is that he gets the winner of that
fight oh john jones one of my favorites
how do you feel watching him fight
because d.c cormier mentioned about his
knockout power at heavyweight which
could be
questioned coming up from light
heavyweight we just watched
israel adasana who's an incredible
fighter go from middleweight to light
heavyweight against john blochovich just
the other week
fought the five rounds got through it uh
but is the power there to knock out the
light heavies
knowing jon jones how do you feel his
power is going to be facing down a ghana
where steve
listen now we you're talking about
specialists he's not much of a striker
you know he's a specialist right one man
in fact he's more like a kung fu fighter
than anything that's martial artist yeah
yeah because he flies through the air
and he gets
his elbow moves and um
he's very sophisticated and fighting as
well when he got his mind right
like his last fight he was just
surviving that guy
but when his mind is right and he's not
fooling around
he's capable of beating anybody i'm not
i'm not from the book that a big
a good big man could be a good small man
too much time so many times in history
and so many different other sports you
saw the the great little man
was supreme to the great big man think
about billy cahn remember
yeah all the way back then jon jones is
one of the greatest of all times a
master
of disaster what he does i mean when he
throws those oblique kicks you know
those
oblique kicks he's throwing in the [ __ ]
sorry mike you know
over here i mean you guys have been
kicked away but
they'll be kicking a big man kicking a
big man doing all that the calf kicks
the whole bit i'm john's probably he's
gonna be moving it's gonna be moving
moving moving you know i like my john he
creates his openings
yeah he comes in and just swinging and
if it lands
and he see you do something that's it he
go crazy and his ability to create
distance
yeah you know is so important yeah right
yeah but those two guys are gonna
disrespect the distances come right at
him
right yeah yeah i think he would be fine
i think he'll be fine too i mean i
i'm not saying anything other than i
think he's going to do a great job and
he's going to come down to may the best
man win that night i'm with him
i think until i see him get beaten i
believe he can beat anybody
it seems that way doesn't it yeah yeah
absolutely but look at these young
uh fighters coming up we have so many
and the female fighters
chinese woman there's two chinese for
the girl and god is kicking everybody's
ass in their way hmm you know two
eight chinese fighters a girl and a
gentleman that's kicking away that uh
wally zang
yeah what's the chick name yeah she's
gonna fight that's her name while he
zang and she's gonna fight uh
that's going to be a fight most
definitely and you know there's there's
so many good fighters i mean that
rosie just let me hug her
those are so beautiful we got mosfed all
coming in is going to fight usman oh
that's gonna be a good fight that's a
big deal fight
what about khabib what could be fitting
you know the thing is just working out
getting staying in shape but i think for
khabib
i believe we'll see him back in the
octagon whether it's uh
the trilogy against um conor mcgregor or
whatever but
khabib needs to be lifted i mean you
know better than anybody an opponent
that lists you
for your training pushes you to that
next level
i think could be because he's made a lot
of money for himself
you know and he's i'm sure he's
comfortable but i don't think it's about
the money as much as him as for the
challenge
and having a a an opponent in front of
him that's going to
say i want to do the six to eight weeks
of training i want to give guys could
fight
him in his way higher well you know
there's
dustin poirier's out there i mean dustin
poirier
is an example of a fighter who's always
been an awesome fighter
but he with a long career of fighting
has become better than ever in the last
two years
as proven with the way he took out
connor in his last fight you know with
the calf kicks i mean his
his fight plan for that fight was just
perfect he's a thinking man's fighter
he'd be a grand opponent but gaby's got
to sit back and watch and see what
happens are they going to make
uh you know the the poirier fight that
just happened are they going to make it
again
you know is there going to be a trilogy
there the beauty of the ufc is
and the matchmakers and dana and all
they put together is
they provide us with so much
entertainment you know it's
it's like every show i think i've seen
like a the greatest fight when i think
i've seen the greatest fight
right another one happens two weeks
later two months later i'm looking at
the greatest fight i'm looking at the
greatest show whole mind
and people might say oh there's nobody
on this card whatever you know i love
when people say that yeah
because then all the fights are awesome
you suck them yep yeah they're shocking
you're so awesome
they're coming out they're proving
themselves left and right every night i
walk in the octagon
for 25 years my passion for what i do i
treat that like my very first night
i have to prove to myself to dana the
fans the powers that be
and especially to the fighters that i
deserve this job
you know and that keeps my passion
flowing i'm going to go out there
saturday night coming up
i'm going to give it my all pay-per-view
next week in ghana stipe going to give
it my all
you'll never hear me talk about last
week i'm always looking to the future
because we're only as good as we are
today that's just my attitude well i
want to take you back real quick
tell me about the elevator fight in the
elevator
oh man tell us about that well
what happened was um and frank and i are
friends frank trigg
and i was on his podcast after that
happened and we both laid it out you can
look on the internet we can hear it out
of frank's voice my voice whatever but
what basically what happened is we had a
fight that night a
fight night of ufc fights and we were at
the hard rock hotel
okay so we're at the hard rock it's
after the fights and i decided to go to
mike
goldberg's room and there's frank trigg
and we all had a drink together
and we saw we're going to go out to
dinner i'm going to go out to a club
later have some fun
so we're on the 10th floor of the hard
rock hotel we walked to the elevator
and when the elevator opens there's dana
white and mike
and uh his security guy tom so we're
walking in the doors have not even
closed
frank immediately who was saying to dana
you know
when are you gonna put me in another
fight and so many words and they were
just exchanging a few things and i'm a
watch freak
okay and dana had this really cool watch
on this watch band
and so here's the elevator we walk in
i'm at the door frank is over here
dana's over here and i turned to dana
dana
what a watch and i'm i'm sorry if i
interrupted the brief moment they were
having
you know him asking for a job or
whatever the case might be because i
don't mean to do that
but when i did that i got a rich hand
he's over here i'm facing here and i get
a rich hand in my throat
and i turn around like frank you hit me
why the f did you hit me
and he said the wrong thing to me he
said well what are you going to do about
it
no no no no so i just i just reacted i
went oh boom you know
and then it was on and now the doors
close and and
uh we're just throwing out each other
for ten floors i mean what is that maybe
we get back to the minute long fight
what does that may be
so the elevator started moving the
elevator doors closed as that happened
and now we're starting to go down the
ten floors that's some big guys and
boom boom boom it was like small areas
so give me an elevator fight no i'm just
kidding so dana's up against the wall
like this and
security guys here and goldberg's here
and and all i was doing was going at it
with frank and it's like
we're going down and and then it just
bam bam bam and then he need me
and one of my friends and i felt that
and then i
shoulder turned him and pushed against
the elevator and he came back and then i
feel the doors opening behind me right
now if you remember the hard rock hotel
where you know the hard rock hotel
on that bottom floor they have all the
memorabilia encased in glass
the way we were going at it we would
have spilled out of the elevator
and god forbid into the glass or
something and it would have been a scene
a scene that i don't want to be part of
right so i just threw my arms in the air
i said we're done we're done we're done
and then it was over and you know the
adrenaline's flowing and
we're laughing and dan automatically
stopped to we stopped yeah we stopped
right and um dana's laughing we're
laughing adrenaline's flowing and i got
blood up and down my shirt
i look at my thumb and i can see the
bone in my thumb you know skin's peeled
back it must have hit his belt buckle or
his watch or you know how things happen
yeah so i'm bleeding dana's smiling i'm
smiling
frank's smiling we're you know hugging
each other like bros like okay we had we
had a 10 of 10 a friendly 10 attempt
right
it happens i missed that when i was
younger you have a tetant you have a
beer
okay so i had to go to the
first aid station i said can you
superglue it they said no we can't got
to go to the hospital right
so i go to i go to the emergency room
it's empty i walk in i'm sitting in the
room waiting for the doctor to come in
and i'm hearing my voice in the next
room announcing the fights because
they're watching the repeat
and the doctor walks in he's like this
the heck are you doing here
right so i got like seven stitches
tetanus shot five hundred dollars you
know
whatever went out had a good time
afterwards
hey you know what guys it was a fun
night i announced the ufc
i had a fun teddy ted an elevator in
front of my boss he knows he doesn't
have a wimp announcing his fighters
went out had some fun i felt like i was
28 years old i'll do it tomorrow night
let's do it
wow it was one of those things and
dana what happened was i didn't tell
anybody because i come from the school
that those that talk don't do and those
that do don't talk right
so yeah tell my mom tell my parents sell
a couple friends or whatever
but then two days later this fighter
named mikey burnett an
old style mma oklahoma fighter comes up
to me goes hey
buff i hear you took it to trig right i
go mikey
i haven't who told you because dana's
telling everybody
it can't hold water yeah holy like ah
that was that you know there's so many
stories you guys have a ton of stories
in the naked city in your careers and
i could tell you so many stories yeah
brawls at after parties i was in a
street fight with chuck liddell and tito
ortiz in london the the famous wait
okay two of them got into a fight no
no no it's it's the famous story um it's
kind of an urban legend type story but
it's always been told
uh where there was a guy named um lee
murray
who was in english some people called
him a gangster whatever but he fought in
the ufc
uh just like tommy hearns just looked
like tommy hearn sin you'd steal you
remember tommy's body right yeah
just could fight long arms you know you
really need to practice your distance
with a guy like that
so i don't know what happened but we
were walking out and i was with um
tito and chuck we were all inside having
a good time
uh partying the potatoes were there the
whole bit but anyway we walk out
and pat milotic somebody was on pat's
back
and kind of like playing with him
choking him but i guess somebody took it
the wrong way
it was a friend of tito's that was on
his back doing that somebody took it the
wrong way came up
cold cocked him he went down a taxi
cab ran over his arm and all hell
started to break loose
so everybody starts the things are
happening tito goes this way lee murray
goes that way what i understand is they
went at it and
lee murray knocked tito down um
but when you're in a street fight and
you have a choice with and chuckledell
was there i don't care who else is there
you follow chuckledown
so i followed chuckledell and i i took
care of his back made sure nobody got on
his back and it was like watching
a movie i mean chuck's just throwing
punches and people are just dropping
he's like bam bam hammer fist down boom
boom boom just walk it through the crowd
right
it was just one of those nights you know
things happen
yeah they did yeah when you're hanging
out with ultimate fighters
but it happens the martial arts code the
boxing code
blood and honor right respect as we're
taught as martial artists
the ufc fighters that i've met as well
as the boxers
it's amazing when you realize how
awesome professional fighters can be
as human beings i mean let's face it it
is the loneliest sport in the world
when that ref says go when that octagon
gate uh
gate closes you're lonely before you
even get in the ring
yeah you train with your friends that
like when i announce when i announce the
fighters i never take my eyes off them
and i don't stand center with all
respect to other announcers
i have to move i gotta
flamboyant but i'll get in their space
you know i'll get over and and
guys like chuck or mirko crow cop is
like they just pop get out of my space
you know but it's like there's a mutual
respect there and i want to take
when i'm announcing a fighter god i wish
i could announce you guys in your prime
i would love to have that experience
but i want to take you what i can give
you everything i have to take you to
that next level you're already enhanced
to where you are
but i have to try and take you that that
next level
and it's just such a moment because i'm
looking into the eye of the tiger i'm
looking into your eyes
and i've seen fear in fighter's eyes i
won't mention the names
but i've that octagon gate is closed and
you can tell that that eight weeks of
training is maybe
they're forgetting it right there you
know that fear factor even their
profession especially when they're at
their very first fight in the octagon
when i've like went to the side into the
blue corner i
i've seen a couple of fighters go
[Laughter]
wanna stop thinking of your head like
are you really ready
i can't say enough about the uh ufc
octagon warriors
as well as the boxing orders my respect
factor is just through the roof
that's that totally would you ever do a
podcast
i i have my own pocket you still do the
it's time podcast this time
i've actually had it for uh almost 13
years i'd love if anybody wants to tune
in just look up bruce buffer it's time
podcast
i have actors fighters it's a lifestyles
podcast
yeah and we talk collecting we talk
about a whole bunch of different stuff
mike
love to have you on the show with zap i
would love to be in the show too yeah
we're gonna do that but please if i mean
if check it out guys
i'm sure you'll you'll enjoy if you're
ufc fans you really enjoy it
okay thank you i love you to see love
you guys ufc
well yo before we get ready go oh we're
going it's your biggest
opportunity it's your chance and your
words put it together
introduce your perfect night of
introducing oh
[ __ ] let's do it baby let's hear it
holy [ __ ] brownsville
brownsville brooklyn and
now this is truly
the moment we've all been
waiting for it
it's time
introducing fighting out of brownsville
new york
usa presenting
the heavyweight undisputed
champion of the world
iron mike
it don't get no better
this is what happens guys i'll announce
the main event
three pounds of water
phenomenal man that was it i feel like i
could have done this
wow bucket list fulfilled yeah
who's that next man oh man
well we know who's going to introduce
you mike you fight again
there's only one person needs to
introduce you and that's the great
legendary michael buffer well that's the
man
he legitimizes the event and he makes it
happen
yeah listen when back in the 80s he was
like [ __ ] a model back in the
80s
man oh yeah yeah yeah i understand
walking the world walking just the cool
dude
over there you know what i just said for
mike um
i do for a lot of fans is that i started
a few years ago
during christmas i put a special thing
out to do an audio or videos where i
introduced ufc fans like
champions in the cage and i was only
doing for a couple weeks but we got so
many orders
and i haven't changed the prices it's
not like i'm trying to sell it right now
but it
it makes my partner kristen and i so
happy
because we get these thank you notes and
they bring tears our eyes you know
i like paying it forward i like doing
things and making people happy
and you know i do this through my site
at brucebuffer.com and i do cameos you
do you're doing cameos right
yeah you have to have people um people
say hey announce my name
you would do those that's what they do
they'll write me in the office
our office or through my website and and
i'll announce their name
birthdays birthdays birth of babies
coming up now
weddings walking down the isle of love
forever
you know that kind of thing you know
i mean announced jesus christ you know
churches have had me like you know did
the sunday
announcement for them yeah are you
serious oh yeah
yeah one time michael even got a deal
for michael he had to announce the devil
and god right it is the announcement
michael did that
how did that work out they worked out
great they loved it they played it in
the church the whole congregation
lucifer and my brothers
the lilly white jesus christ i've had
guys write me or
cameo orders come in and they'll say i
need you to do my eulogy you're not even
dead yet
wow they want to have like a
pre-recorded thing for when god forbid
that day comes
that's a little weird that's the ego
yeah you know the biggest ego want to be
out of the funeral see who came
but you know what's fun it's just uh i
come from the school
around me i have a three-foot theory i
like everybody around me to be healthy
prosperous and happy
i think about that before myself and it
all comes back you know
when i'm in business or with a friend
it's just an unselfish attitude just it
works for me guys
the way i like the way i like to roll
yeah i like it
i like it roll your shell and roll i do
as best i can do that when we have a
bite to eat or something
yeah well ladies and gentlemen there you
have it
that's hot boxing here with your boy zab
judah mike tyson
and i'm so happy to be here i'm bruce
popper audacious
bruce yes bodacious
[Music]
mike tyson raves in full bloom captured
the art of fighting the hollywood
reporter says
it's mallet meet scorsese
in full bloom available now on amazon
prime video
you